[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday and odd
day in November Hank I've just finished
rereading the Brotherhood 2.0 rules the
rules state that I have to make a video
every other week day for 365 days all of
2007 but no where to the rules state
that I have to make a long video
particularly if for instance I am
experiencing radical asymmetry of the
ear due to a massive ear infection it's
like me and Ross Perot all I want is my
ear symmetry back oh and it would be
awesome if I could hear out of both ears
Hank I've been told that I should be
feeling better soon which is good
because until I feel better you should
not expect the videos to be either long
or funny Hank I hope that your weekend
is painless or at the very least that
there's a lot of percocet involved don't
worry about me my doctors have been
generous I'll see you on Monday
PS thanks to nerdfighter Jen for making
the peep that looks like me
so in PPS just because I'm only rocking
one year doesn't mean I don't have time
for the scavenger hunt but your clue
isn't ready just yet
something will show up somewhere at some
point this weekend though nerdfighters
don't forget to be awesome